Well the weather outside is frightful, and
the fire is so delightful, but at the risk
of sounding spiteful, salting roads ain’t
rightful.
That’s why this story I did write, full
of alternatives that might pull us just that
much further in our environmental fight, fool!
You’re not a fool.
That’s just, you know...I like rhyming.
Welcome back to DNews.
I’m Matt Lieberman.
Every winter, communities the world over prepare
for months of icy roads and snowstorms.
But in the United States, we fight back against
the cold and damp with a massive amount of
road salt.
How much?
Try 22 million tons.
That’s roughly 137 pounds of salt per American
citizen.
That’s crazy, right?
We’ve been praying at the altar of road
salt since the 1940s and 50s, as highways
changed the face of the nation.
Suddenly, truckers and commuters alike didn’t
have days to wait for snow and ice to melt.
Salt was our solution to increase traction
on roads and simultaneously melt the ice and
snow on them.
The benefits are obvious: According to a 1992
study, salting roads reduces car accidents
during and after winter storms by a whopping
87%.
That translates to potentially thousands of
lives saved.
So why are we making a stink about something
that works?
Well our dependency has massive downsides.
Sodium chloride is corrosive.
It eats through cars and trucks, bridges,
even concrete.
A study in Utah estimates that Americans spend
between $16 and $19 billion a year to repair
the damage.
There’s got to be a cheaper solution, and
one without the additional environmental effects
of road salt.
When the salt melts, it steadily runs off
into our water supplies, increasing the salinity
and chloride levels of lakes and rivers and
killing wildlife.
A December 2014 study from the US Geological
Survey found that 29% of urban streams exceeded
safe levels of chlorine for at least part
of the year, and that the levels of chlorine
have risen in 89% of urban streams overall.
Additionally, salt on the road attracts animals
like deer, moose, and elk, which poses constant
risks of collision.
Additionally, we’ve now used so much salt
on our roads that we’re now facing a salt
shortage.
What are we to do?
Well, there are alternatives out there, but
unfortunately most of them still involve salt
in some capacity.
For example, Wisconsin cities have taken to
pre-soaking their roads with cheese brine
before storms.
Now, there is still salt or a salt/sand mixture
in the cheese brine, but there is far less
of it, and pre-salting the roads makes it
difficult for ice and snow to stick to them.
Other communities have taken to using beet
juice in conjunction with road salt to reduce
the amount of salt used, and others still
use calcium chloride instead of sodium chloride.
Calcium chloride is less harmful to vegetation,
but is more corrosive to concrete and metal.
However, the following options are the most
environmentally friendly: Sand and ashes both
offer better traction and have low albedo,
which means that they absorb sunlight very
easily, heating roads quickly to melt ice.
Kitty litter is also an option, providing
excellent traction, though for a high price.
There’s also a product called Ecotraction,
which is a volcanic material that provides
traction and is safe to the environment and
to animals.
So now we want to hear from you.
What is your solution to America’s road
salt addiction?